you have a tweet about shackleton saying
here's a photo of shackleton's medical
kit from his storied expedition to
antarctica in the 1910s
some perigoric for pain
some laxatives
only the essentials
would you put laxative under the
essentials
anyway sorry to interrupt
when i worked as a ship doctor in
antarctica in 2018 i had a huge cabinet
full of meds and even ekg machine
so
if you can comment sort of on that
contrast first of all your own journey
how harsh was it how difficult was it
and
given that context
can you think about how hard
shackleton's journey was
i think the difference is unimaginably
stark
one thing i do want to point out is that
the use of laxatives early in the 20th
century and before that it was they were
used for a surprising
number of ailments where they probably
did not help at all but um i think that
was a holdover from sort of the old
theory of medicine the humoral theory
where you have to balance the fluids in
the body and so causing people to vomit
causing them to have diarrhea or
purposely taking blood out of them in
bloodletting
was a big part and i think that crazy
use of laxatives was um maybe a holdover
from that time
but that being said
they were probably not eating very high
fiber food on that expedition so perhaps
laxatives could have been helpful you
know there's a lot of seal
um
penguin and seal meat being eaten which
is not super high in fiber
so i don't want to discount the
importance of laxatives in that setting
but that wouldn't be the essential thing
if you're thinking if you're thinking of
a tiny kit that has only the essentials
i mean pain
yes laxatives
maybe not i think the the medical kit
possibilities were much now narrower
back then you know this was um before
antibiotics before
i think germ theory might have been you
know it was known but um there wasn't
much to do about it um so the
availability of medicines i mean that's
something that exploded over the course
of the 20th century so what i can put in
a backpack today filled with modern
medications whether injectable or to be
taken orally is
you know just um many orders magnitude
greater than what they had back then
um so when i i mean when i went my
expedition was nothing like shackleton's
i was on a huge cruise ship
with 160 japanese passengers
who came with their own translators um
and
as i said i had a cabinets not just one
cabinet many cabinets full of
medications both injectable some patches
uh some pills
um i was very impressed actually which
with what was available there um and i
didn't have to use a a lot of it
thankfully though i did use some of it
for people
um but uh and i i slept and you know i
got free room and board um on the ship
so every southern summer cruise ships
go take people to antarctica the
southern atlantic islands like the
falklands and other other parts of the
south pacific and then in the northern
summer the same kind of cruise ship
explosion happens you know going to
greenland and iceland and svalbard and
franz josef land and other parts of the
north alaska
so and every ship needs a doctor
so it's a great opportunity they want
specifically er doctors you know to deal
with emergencies
but uh you're really working in the
middle of nowhere and all you have is
the medications there on the ship and
supplies and your knowledge and
experience and so it's it's a very
different experience than working in a
high-tech modern hospital with every bit
of technology and every sub-specialist
consultant available
but i sort of like that challenge i mean
i like going to the ends of the earth
it's beautiful it's exciting it's
fascinating
practicing medicine in those settings is
extra challenging and really um makes
you hones some of your skills which is
part of the reason that i sought them
out
do you uh see echoes of some of that
same effort i've gotten a chance to
interact with astronauts and those kinds
of folks
working on space missions do you see
some of those same echoes of challenging
efforts going out into space and maybe
landing on mars and maybe beginning to
build a small
colony on mars yeah i think the health
care that is needed will be a big part
of that you know obviously we're
probably gonna send overall quite
healthy people uh but there's a lot of
medical decisions to make about what
should be brought what should be
expected you know to some extent a lot
i've had a lot of doctors say oh my
goodness i can't believe you work in the
middle of nowhere what do you do if
someone you know gets a brain bleed like
falls hits their head needs a
neurosurgeon i mean the obvious answer
is they die you know
things when you're in the middle of
antarctica
things kill you that wouldn't if you're
inside a university hospital that's
fully equipped to help with every
problem that arises
mars takes that to a crazy extreme
obviously
i know that even going to antarctica
different countries have had different
strategies i believe it was australia
used to
kind of just in anticipation remove
people's gallbladders
uh just so that it wouldn't get inflamed
because that is a very common medical
emergency so they would just remove it
beforehand even though it was not
diseased at all just so that while
they're stuck in antarctica over the
winter for instance um that wouldn't be
a problem you know there's many other
issues that can arise
but so those are some decisions to make
maybe the people who go into mars should
have their appendix removed their
gallbladder removed maybe they should
have a cardiac cath to see if they have
coronary artery disease just to know
their chances of getting a heart attack
there though it's not always predictive
you know it's hard to predict who's
going to get a heart attack but
maybe with all the data around today
we'll get you know better at predicting
but that would be a huge part you know
we can't have people the few peop few
pioneers in a mars colony dying of heart
attacks and things like that anticipate
stuff would you go
you've gone to some harsh conditions to
be a doctor would you go to mars to be a
doctor um it would definitely be
amazing i think
because i have a wife and two small
children probably not in the cards for
me at this point
but
you humans with your human attachments
sex and death
if you just put more priority on the
death than the sex i think would be
uh
better off no
i would love to go to mars and actually
i you know i practice high altitude
medicine in nepal space medicine is sort
of an extension of that you know the air
is just much thinner like non-existent
you know as you go higher in the
mountains the things that happen to
human physiology are very bizarre and
strange and and still not well explained
by science and in space it's just like a
crazy extension of high altitude
you